نحن الآن في نقطة تحول رئيسية
من كونها شركة اتصالات إلى كونها
تقنية وأعتقد أننا لسنا
الشركة الكبيرة الوحيدة التي تبحث عنها ، فنحن
ننقلها حقًا إلى وقت ننظر فيه
إلى
المستهلك الرقمي  المنتجات الرقمية للمؤسسات
وتتطلع حقًا إلى تقديم حلول
ليس فقط توفير الاتصال فيما يتعلق
بمسألة الحجم ، هل لديك الحجم
اللازم للتنافس
مع فيريزونس 18 عامًا وفودافون
للاتصالات الألمانية
الذين لديهم من هم ضخمون جدًا
لدرجة أنهم يهيمنون على السوق العالمية
حيث  نحن نحاول حقًا تمييز
أنفسنا
وهي تجربة العملاء التي
نستثمرها حقًا في ذلك سواء من
الجانب التقني في شبكاتنا للحصول
على شبكات متطورة وأعطيك
مثالاً في المنطقة للسنة
الثانية على التوالي.  هي أسرع شبكة للهاتف المحمول
في العالم ، فنحن أيضًا من
البنية التحتية لوجهة نظر الألياف الضوئية لدينا أيضًا أعلى نسبة
اختراق للألياف في العالم ، لذلك
نوضح هنا بعض الأشياء التي
لقد فعلنا في المعرض ما إذا كانوا
مشاركين دوليين في البنية التحتية للاتصالات السحابية
والإنترنت وأيضًا تجربة الزائر
ويمكنك الانتقال من منطقة إلى أخرى إذا
أتيت إلى هنا ، فنحن نعرض عدد الكاميرات
الموجودة حولها وكلها متصلة بواسطة  5g
يديرونها ، يساعدون في إدارة حركة المرور ،
وإدارة التذاكر ، وإدارة التجربة
للتأكد من أن الأشخاص لديهم تجربة رائعة
في هذا المعرض
، من الذكاء جدًا أن هذا يعمل بشكل أفضل
من هاتفي ، إنه سلس تمامًا
وأنت تعرف هذا الأمر برمته ، الاتصال الهاتفي
كما يمكنني  اطرح هذا السؤال
بمجرد قول مشكلة whatsapp
، فالحقيقة هي أنه في هذا البلد
لا يمكن إجراء مكالمات هاتفية عبر whatsapp
لأشخاص هنا إذا سألتهم قالوا إن
هذا لحماية
المورد المحلي الذي هو أنت
لحمايتك وسأكون في  صالح
تغيير القواعد التي سمحت بالاتصال
جيدًا ، دعني أبدأ
الاتصال عبر الإنترنت أولاً ، يتوفر الأمان أه
وللمنظم قائمة بيضاء محددة و blac  قائمة التطبيقات
التي يمكن أن تعمل وهذا لأسباب
يمكن أن
تعرفها بشكل أفضل ولكن
اليوم وأعطيك أمثلة كبيرة لتطبيقات أخرى ،
على سبيل المثال ، تعمل عبر
شبكتنا كل من فرق Microsoft الثابتة والمتنقلة على
حد سواء إصدار المؤسسة
مثل  بالإضافة إلى أن الإصدار الفردي
يعمل ، فهل
السؤال
هو هل
الصوت عبر بروتوكول الإنترنت أو الاتصال عبر الإنترنت
متاح تمامًا ، فهل
جميع التطبيقات متاحة وليست كلها ،
لذا سأعيد صياغة ما
إذا كنت ستفضل
تغيير القواعد للسماح للمنظم؟  أشياء مثل
ما هو متاح بالفعل ، هناك
شيء يسمى
خطة الاتصال عبر الإنترنت حيث يدفع العملاء
الذين يريدون أيًا من التطبيقات الأخرى
رسومًا رمزية لاستخدامها بحيث
تكون هذه الحماية كافية حتى إذا
أصبح تطبيق whatsapp متاحًا كجزء من
هذا والمنظم و
ترى الكيانات الأخرى أنه من
المفيد أن تكون على قائمتهم البيضاء
من وجهة نظر الاتصالات
من وجهة نظري طالما أن  العملاء
يدفعون ثمنها ضمن باقة البيانات الخاصة بهم
أو ضمن خطة الاتصال عبر الإنترنت
أنا سعيد بها